Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Tony from the
Bay Area? Tony from the Bay Area.
Welcome to The David Pakman Show.
Tony, from the Bay Area. You have to accept my
invitation in order to talk to me. There's Tony.
Speaker 4: Okay. Hello? Hello.
Okay. My question is about if.
Trump had the the ability and he knew he was going
to be arrested by the ability to flee like Edward
Snowden to Russia for the rest of his life to
avoid being arrested or facing criminal charges.
Do you think he would take that option?
Speaker 1: Nope. Can I tell you why?
Speaker 4: Yes.
Speaker 1: So Trump is a malignant narcissist.
Malignant narcissists believe that they are the
smartest people in the room. They believe they can
talk their way into or out of any situation.
There are already articles from the New York
Times and The Guardian based on sources close to
Trump that Trump wants to be handcuffed. He wants
to be perp walked. He's seeing all of this as a
publicity tool. He has no understanding of the
actual criminal legal risk to him and believes
that he will absolutely come out on top. Now,
that may be true, but even if it was likely
that it would work out poorly for him,
where it might actually make sense to try to
flee to Russia. Narcissists like Trump never
believe that. And so Trump would not come to
believe his best move is to flee to Russia.
Speaker 4: I agree with you. And I had one
more quick question, if that's okay. Sure.
Neil. You know what? I just forgot it,
so I'll let you go. Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Tony from the Bay Area.
Beautiful question. Let's go next to
Matteo from D.C.. Matteo from D.C.
Welcome to the program. So great to have you on.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. It's great to be here.
David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Perfect. All right. So I have
a pretty quick question. Sure. It's not
political at all. So as far as the memberships
go, I primarily listen to your podcast on the
Apple Podcasts app. And usually that's with
ads and everything. And so I was wondering
if you would ever considered charging for an
ad free version for people who just listen to
podcasts through a particular app, be it like,
you know, Amazon or Apple just so that we.
Speaker 1: Already have it. It's a member. It's
an existing member benefit when you sign up for
membership. There's a link in the member section
where you can generate a custom commercial free
audio podcast link for yourself and then you
just dump it into whatever podcast player you
use. It works beautifully with Apple Music or
iTunes or whatever it's called these days. So
we're we're ten years ahead of you, my friend.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, No, I know about that. But,
you know, some other podcasters have like
a civic membership once that comes straight
through that app. And so there's maybe not
people like me who are willing to double dip
who already pay for a membership, but would
also just love that like sort of you're.
Speaker 1: Saying like an iTunes
only or Spotify only premium version.
Speaker 2: Exactly. Because I think that
there are probably a lot of people who
just primarily listen to it from that app,
just purely out of convenience. It's an.
Speaker 1: Interesting idea. I think the concern
is always spreading ourselves too thin. And then
I will get flooded with emails from people
saying, What's the difference between the
premium podcast through Spotify versus the one
on your website that I can add to Spotify? So let
me look into that. But I would be concerned
about spreading ourselves too thin and just
creating a customer service nightmare.
Speaker 2: Got you. Okay. Makes sense.
Just wanted to ask that question because
there aren't, you know, crazy people like
me who are willing to double dip and get
both. But, yeah, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks. Matteo from
DC. And by the way, one more thing. YouTube
is launching podcasting in and of itself through
the YouTube music thing. And everything we do is
going to be available there, and I think the
functionality will be fantastic. Let's take
a very quick break. We're going to go right
back to Discord and hear from more people. So
if you're holding on to talk to me, don't go
anywhere. We're going right back in a moment.